[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the true Geordie podcast
today's guest is Richard grunin I did
say that right yeah yeah uh you've got a
background in Psychology and pivoted
specifically in narcissism and
narcissists and I discovered you on
Instagram and I was like who because so
many things you say resonate with like
people I've met in the past okay uh
hopefully not me but you can tell us
today if I'm a narcissist but I guess a
good place to start is kind of like what
is a narcissist specifically because
we've all got like traits of narcissism
and hell I mean I work on camera so
obviously there's some of that in me but
how would you define a narcissist well
there is I mean there is such a thing as
as healthy narcissism and yeah you are
supposed to have
uh narcissistic traits like if all your
narcissistic traits were taken away from
you would struggle to function in the
world so there isn't there's there's
narcissism as they would talk about it
clinically in a psychiatric context and
then there's narcissism on the internet
which basically means anybody who's
upset you they're a nurse the thing
I'm going to run a poll actually on
Instagram and on YouTube to see how many
people who claim they understand
narcissism know what the nine traits
from the DSM are because I imagine most
people don't so narcissism is a response
to a traumatic environment in childhood
and it means that you completely give up
on real reality because it's it's too
overwhelming it's too painful so the
child chooses to live in delusion so
is one of the things we never talk about
narcissism for a narcissist to be a
narcissist they need to have had a
psychotic break with reality and they
now need to live in an ongoing
continuous break with reality
people who've dealt with narcissistic
personality types will recognize this
because when you argue with them they
keep insisting on fantasy so you're like
no I know the dates I know the times I
know what I said I know what happened
and you insist on that and they insist
on changing it back into their fantasy
and we'll be on the outside of this
going well you're just [__] lying I
can't stop you from lying all the time
and yes they are deliberately lying and
they are deliberately gaslighting the
target but they also live in a lie their
life is a lie so the way to think of
this is imagine you have a human being
uh there were a small child once an
authentic real vulnerable small child
things happen that they couldn't
tolerate so they built a shell around
themselves and inside of that shell they
split from pain for reality and when
they look through the shell they never
see reality as it is it's always blurred
the shell is a filter
and they see on the inside of the cell a
mirror that they've created as but not
not a clear mirror like a fun house
circus sort of a mirror that shows them
what they choose to see in order to
survive so when you're arguing with a
narcissist and and they're Clinging On
stubbornly so they have to be stubborn
for it to be MPD it's a rigid
personality disorder it's it's because
they're like um holding onto a life raft
they're at Sea they're in crisis
perpetually they live their lives in
crisis that's why they go from one drama
to the next that's all they know and
their narcissistic delusion is the life
raft they cling on to so people come to
me and say can't you give them therapy
can't you help them all right how how am
I going to convince a child to let go of
of a survival strategy that they've been
using since they were three or four
years old
I've known multiple people have trauma
as children yeah
and a lot of them still live in the real
world a lot of them accept that trauma a
lot of them you know eventually try and
heal from it and and and and stare it
you know in the face I guess I wondered
why these personality types pick this
fake reality well I can give you an
answer that's is it a choice even I
don't know choice is a difficult word so
so now now we're into the Badlands of
not just Psychiatry but psychoanalytic
theory we've got to go to Freud we've
got to go Young
to make it easy for people watching so
that they can walk away with something
like anybody who's teaching
psychoanalytic theory would have a ship
fit if they heard me say this but
broadly speaking you know you have like
a black sheep in the family they can't
do right for doing wrong so if you're
the black sheep it doesn't matter what
you do you can't do everything wrong
then you have Golden Child they can't do
wrong for doing right so you could have
like a brother and a sister raised
together with two brothers in the same
environment One turns towards like
hardcore codependency phone responding
being servile and the other one turns
towards narcissistic tyranny why
potentially one potential answer for
this would be the entitlement that was
installed in them by a parent who's
mentally ill because what was the what
what was the environment that they were
raising that was so traumatic they've
had mentally ill parents splitting as an
element of narcissism you're either all
good or you're all bad or there are
parts of UL addresses though one half of
you is good and one half of you is bad
this is mentally ill uh thinking but
it's mirrored in the children so if the
parent splits and puts projects all of
their if they're mentally ill and weak
essentially not emotionally mature all
the bad stuff for me that I don't like
that's going in you you're the black
sheep all the good stuff that I do like
narcissistically probably fantasy based
it's going in you The Golden Child it's
more likely that child's gonna be able
to to narcissism needs to function it's
it's a it's a strategy if you think like
military or combat or you've got like
MMA fighters here they have a strategy
that will work in one environment that
might not in another environment so so
there is evidence in the psychoanalytic
theory land that some children try
narcissism they try to become
narcissists but it's being out of them
it has to work long enough for the child
to take it through into adults okay so
this is a great point for because I feel
like in the way Society is moving in
social media and how important social
media has become that people's everyday
lives yeah that reward system that
you're describing it's so there in
social media now if you are a narcissist
like we've seen like I know people who
are literally giving out you know advice
on on social media and you see like
these pictures with these quotes that
they're posting their lives their
personal lives I know them are [__] show
they don't even wouldn't wouldn't you
even say that's the norm like like the
people who actually are the most
aggressively online going you know be
disciplined and open up your damn room
well they turn out to be drug addicts
this was something that young noticed
said that that he specifically cited man
he said The more a man publicly talks
about discipline and morality and all
the rest of it the more likely he is
personally to be in Shadow activation
and Shadow possession so Shadow is the
disavowed parts of ourselves that we
don't want to look at we don't want to
see we push them down but if you do that
they can come back and take you so the
more somebody's performatively saying oh
I have a morality I have discipline I
have this and that who's saying the more
likely it is that their life will be as
you say a [__] [__] show up
absolutely and and
it's in that reward system that we've
created of likes and and clicks and all
of this it it gives more than ever I
would assume
um narcissists a structure to win and
for this to continue as long as they
needed it 100 it's an economy isn't it
yeah it's like an ecosystem and an
economy Cloud chasing yeah yeah which is
profit in that in that ecosystem and it
now translates to real profit it's real
money you know it's not like oh you're
just acquiring a bunch of digital likes
now these people are making real money
in the real world through those digital
likes and yes that environment rewards
uh aggressive Psychopathic narcissism
obnoxious exhibit exhibitionist
exhibitist
exhibitionist thank you yeah I never
thought I'd know a word that you didn't
mean I'll tell you let me think
and and and going off I mean look
there's the extreme examples like Andrew
for example who you know
shouts about uh old ways of living your
life and men should be men and meanwhile
this man is literally a pimp oh yeah
pimping our girls on a webcam which is
the complete opposite of the morality
that he like the the hypocrisy Within
These people yeah it's Rife and and Tate
is an extreme example but I know
people who are a lot cleverer than tears
are disguising it and they boast about
you know they're a great businessmen and
they've achieved this at the other in
the reality is like you know as as
someone who's in the know I know that
these people who claim to be this that
and the other they they're talking [__]
yeah and the actions of what they that
because they're clutching they're trying
to get these clicks these likes and this
uh reward system like people with real
fulfillment and self-worth they don't
really give a [__] about all that no no
a real fulfillment and self-worth is of
no use to that economy so in a sense
like what I would say what I've been
railing against for a while
um My Little soapbox is consumer
capitalism and honestly real love
authenticity and vulnerability is the
enemy of consumer capitalism and is the
enemy of the social media platforms if
you're in love with your girlfriend you
can have an amazing dopamine releasing
serotonin releasing Day by taking a walk
along the canal here and going and
having a [__] sandwich in a little
shop that's useless to me I want you on
my platforms I want you striving hurting
anxious that you're not getting likes
envious of others aggressively competing
with others that's useful to me also you
won't buy anything bro and it's it's
created a world where it's the climbing
of the ladder no matter what like I will
if I've Gotta Throw you under the bus
yeah to get myself ahead yep I don't
care
um what I would say I'm not I'm not
really in the the podcast podcast game
but somebody who consumes it as a
customer from the outside looking in
your game I think has gotten way nastier
in the last two years so true it used to
be a bunch of lads just chatting and
having a laugh and now you the whole
tone The Stance the positioning of it
and I understand it's capitalism there's
more money in it now than there ever was
before there's real clout there's people
who will be the leaders of countries in
the future who are now social media
influencers I believe they'll all do
like uh valensky type thing we'll see
people pivot into politics for sure from
podcasting I've got mates I've got
trigonometry I'm looking uh constantly
and he's do you ever watch trigonometry
it's it's like a police it's a much more
political podcast but brilliant guy and
I'm watching him and I'm like I think
this is a practice run for something
else and he's doing great at that well
we've seen the London real guy who tried
to become mayor of London and I mean
you're smirking there but if we're
talking about narcissism there's a
candidate you know what can I say I've
had my run-ins with him since like two
times oh really by the way this yeah I
had no idea no no no no that was a
genuine but what does it mean if you say
I've had a running with Brian Rose like
like I I've had my who hasn't I had a
little disagreement with them once and
and I found his whole
switch up so strange disingenuous yeah
and that really easy he's nicknamed as
the grifter who keeps on grifting though
across the internet and it and and
there's someone who could have if if the
narcissist in him was under control he
had something special at one I mean
we're going off on a charger but he had
something there with London reel and his
mate who was his best friend basically
was like uh Nick I think his name was he
was like he absolutely stabbed me in the
back got me out the way and just he
couldn't keep himself under control and
go for real happiness it was more more
I'm glad you brought out because we can
relate this straight back to what we're
talking about with narcissistic
personality disorder uh neck yeah the
South African lad lovely guy from what I
could tell lovely sincere and you know
what killed it he went away he took
psychedelics he came back to Brian post
Enlightenment on psychedelics and sat
opposite Brian and said I love you I
love you like a brother and showed him
real authentic emotion he was [__] you
stole Brian's eyes like Tony turns into
a reptile he was like well you're gone
do you know what it is it's an
interesting point though because I've
definitely felt like I've I've come at
life in relationships especially in
business with an open heart and it has
done me no good it is the amount of
people who [__] me over I'm like I feel
like a [__] at this point like it's
unbelievable
um and yeah it
unfortunately this reward system is is a
big reason for that I feel like because
if they if there wasn't that like I can
use you to further myself them there
would be none of that backstabbing
really there would be no reason for it
but I guess those people will then have
gravitated into a different industry
well and that's that's where like as an
outsider I'm standing on the sidelines I
mean it really I can give multiple
examples of this
um as being a guest on different
podcasts it was Jolly it was silly it
was like come on we'll have a oh here we
go we're gonna have a chat we'll talk
about and then it got super aggressive
earlier podcast soon for example I don't
know how aware of it you are but
basically there was a whole thing over
there with Joe Rogan is the king yes put
put the minute Joe Rogan moved out of
L.A in the Texas yes all of the people
who were left seem to be like okay now
who's the king and he kept and the
amount of infighting and bitching and
and like real serious oh yeah [__] went
on yeah yeah and these I'm talking about
40 50 year old people here yeah yeah
it's embarrassing and that's what power
does man but there's a hundred million
dollars on the table and you know
[__] 100 million and you you must
have seen it in business yourself forget
100 million what will people do for 50
Grand yeah I mean they will do horrible
things to each other for well 50 Grand
way less than that I mean around
Liverpool than that people too the worst
things a human being could do for far
less money than that for some people the
the 100 million and that level of Fame
it's almost like some personalities
shouldn't be in contact with that kind
of money and that kind of thing because
it just warps them completely yeah they
can't control themselves not at all not
at all so that's the narcissistic
delusion so as I think the point that
you were sort of making is like some
people may be a sort of latent half
narcissist not yet fully formed then
they're exposed to their social media
Fame economy bang it just destroys them
and they go full now assist at that
point and I must admit I I definitely
had a moment where I felt like I'm
slipping away here yeah like when when
when a kid from Newcastle gets more
money than he ever expected to yeah I
was indulgent and and there was not a
lot of self-control it was let me buy
this car I don't need let me spend money
on [__] and I had to have a a humbling
and I really did have a humbling and but
and I'm so grateful for that because it
helped me snap out of that road I was
going down and that isn't me or you're
going to show up on Yachts with your
non-checky lines of coke and well it was
embarrassing I look back at some
pictures of myself and I genuinely hate
what I'm looking at I'm like you [__]
Pratt but but that's why you get
rewarded for absolutely so there's a
point you made before like so you
mentioned authenticity if me and you
want to become the top level social
media influencers deep conversations
about vulnerability and authenticity
ain't gonna get us there it's Yachts
it's girls in thongs it's being the
obnoxious prick it was like what color
is your Lambo and the people who suck
those people off and and
it's embarrassing they're more
embarrassing actually I think I I find
the Friendship groups around those
people the most embarrassing because
you're the reason that this narcissist
has not been able to even have a prayer
of waking up because you're positively
reinforcing all of this crap 100 and and
I mean
it it usually takes me longer to get to
that point like what you're talking
about is what the real pandemic is it's
not a pandemic of narcissism it's a
pandemic of indulgence they say that
like at the moment the most recent
research I looked at six percent of the
population of males have full-blown
clinical MPD it's quite high four
percent of females
how is that happening how are we the
rest of the tribe allowing some of our
tribal members four out of a hundred to
act like absolute [__] because we
only Define narcissistic personality
disorder by the social interactions you
have to behave very badly to the people
around you you're almost on a sliding
scale of psychopathy at that point okay
and it's us that's indulging them why do
we do that we we didn't always if we
were in a smaller tribal situation if
somebody was being a real dick and not
working and not hunting and stealing
your hunt he just wouldn't come back
from a hump wouldn't they we'd go
fishing and then suddenly he'd fall in
the River social media brings comparison
and comparison as the thief of joy as
they seem right so we're a lot of people
feel inferior yeah and and they're
looking at these people who are winning
as they say yes and it there is aspiring
to have that one day so even though
because when you've never heard the
money it feels like the be all in end
all and that's why I was so drawn to the
car and the thing that I've never had
before once you get in it I mean it
really is I mean after the first few
times it's anticlimactic you realize
what the [__] have I done here but you
have to kind of experience that yeah to
realize it is not what people make it
out to be and that happiness as you say
is going down and getting a sandwich
with your lass and having a nice day
that's actually true happiness the rest
of it is it's just what car you're
driving is really irrelevant at that
moment it's like like you say I mean
it's just you sat on your ass in a
[__] car going somewhere the whole
point of the rest of it is the reactions
you get from other people that's exactly
right by the way so that's the [__]
drug that's and that's what you pay for
absolutely like you can drive a nice
secondhand BMW for about 25 Grand you
don't need a Lambo for two but the point
the point for me what you've just really
kneeled into a memory of mine was if I
was driving that lovely car a down a
country road with no one on the country
road it would be nice but I would
wouldn't be getting that dopamine
[__] flooding into the brain but when
I was in Newcastle and I knew people
were going there he is yeah that I I got
off on that yes and and I'm ashamed of
saying that to be honest but it's the
reality of it I really did enjoy it
because in my head I was still that poor
kid showing everyone yeah look at me now
yeah but really like
they didn't care all right they cared
for a second and then they went back to
their life and didn't give a [__] but
your brain our dumb brains because the
way we've evolved still give us the
reward yeah and it's whether you fall
prey to the Trek you're going wow this
is really good I'm the man
or do you have the moment of reflection
to be like ah you might not be them you
might just be a prick in a loud car
genuinely that is exactly what I was and
me you've absolutely [__] nailed it
um and and unfortunately
yeah that is what everyone seems to be
chasing though that's the goal for a lot
of people out there it's really sad I
was I was just saying I'm moving to to
uh Dubai and moving the business
everything over there and there's a
really really strong narcissistic
materialistic culture there there's even
an area I think it's called jbr where
everybody goes to drive their Ferraris
their Lambos all and they just clog it
up with traffic on a Friday Saturday
night and all it is is people just
looking at each other in different cars
and that's that's the that's the night
out that's the fun
how stupid are we as human animals to
think that that's a good use of time
what you mentioned before about having
the experience though that's what if
you're going to talk like spirituality
and real emotional growth that's
Transcendence it's not to avoid it it's
to make the money buy the car sit in it
fart in it and go this is the same as
farting in a Vauxhall accident where
it's the same it doesn't fly over track
this is the funny thing that happened
the other day is I I had an issue with
my car got a insurance uh car and it was
one of the worst cars I've ever driven
in my life right it was a Toyota but it
was like the lowest version of a Toyota
I've ever [__] driven in and it had
been God knows how many years since I've
driven in a car like that since I was 18
and I actually like that yeah and
actually thought you know what if you
ask me grafting my balls off yeah to try
and you know show people yeah and now
I'm back in this car I'm like God what
the [__] have I been doing like yeah you
know it just made us laugh because I was
like this is perfectly good and and one
thing just to Pivot into relationships
with a narcissist because I've I find
this fascinating because I I've
definitely witnessed them and and
um and and I'm I wouldn't necessarily
say I'd been in a relationship with a
narcissist but definitely felt not heard
not listened to when and been in that
scenario that you told before about
you're trying to use logic against
someone who's
really in a fantasy world so yeah can
you describe what what that side of what
you've learned about is like
so uh for anybody who is in a
relationship with a narcissist or they
suspect they are the the jump off point
that I would always say is like remember
that there's no such thing as equal with
a narcissist their sense of what equal
is they hate horizontal they hate adult
to adult communication that's no good
they're a kind of a God in their own
universe so in transactional analysis
terms they don't do adult adult
vulnerable communication they do
parent-child communication so they're
top down so they're very hierarchical
and for them vertical and standing over
you that's equal and when you shift it
and you're like I'm gonna say no it'll
be more equal if we're both doing
they're like no no they get stressed
they get angry you can actually inflict
narcissistic injury which induces their
narcissistic rage which means they'll be
punishing you in a disproportionate and
extremely hostile way for a long time
just by asking for decent human behavior
just by you asking them to be a
reasonable adult to calm down to come
you know to come and have a chat to go
to counseling to fix the problem you'll
induce narcissistic injury
is one of the things that they do
threatening
yeah yeah it's it's one of the nine
traits from the DSM it's extremely
bullying and threatening behavior and
and in complex post-traumatic stress
disorder terms we call this uh the
narcissistic personality disorder is a
fight foreign response so their way in
of acting in the world is to bully love
out of people they'll try they're
emotional terrorists they've gone to the
Head love me or else
but not just love me worship me submit
to me or else so that yeah bullying if
you felt bullied if you're not in a
relationship with an MPD you're in a
narcissistically definitely I've
definitely been in a situation before
where someone's made
threats yeah when I was in
um agreeing yeah to you know whatever
that the the issue was at the time and I
remember feeling uh like something was
hanging over me yeah you know like it's
not it's certainly not pleasant
um and in terms of how that how does
that differ from male to female because
obviously in well I mean not not
necessarily nowadays but like
stereotypically men are the strong one
women or the you know the soft feminine
one and you know how how does this come
out of them in different ways well men
and women are biologically different for
sure we're stronger I mean we'll have
less of that on this one
all right I've got one of these male
feministers yeah the the threat level of
course is is different and um it's very
very hard within a psychoanalytic theory
within Psychiatry and Psychotherapy to
for us to really pass which parts of
these things are cultural and which
parts of these are biological like
what's learned and what's innate so of
course narcissistic abuse being played
out by a man would be different to a
woman if a man goes to the point of
physical violence we'll then say this is
psychopathic and narcissistic abuse
because you could be arrested for it
which means that psychopathy with female
narcissistic abuse it's probably going
to be harder to tell so if I if you if
you come over here now and grab me and
rip my shirt and [__] do as you
[__] told or smash it even if you
don't punch me if you catch it on camera
it's obvious I'm under threat if a woman
says to me I say to a woman I'm gonna go
and see my family now and she says yeah
go on then
and I get this feeling like oh [__]
yeah go on go yeah go see your family
like you do you're bastard it doesn't
say you bastard and you just feel it who
are you gonna tell
well I told my girlfriend I was coming
to see you and you know what she said to
me go on then well fine what's the
problem it's the meta communication is
the way that they'll it because and this
isn't me having a pop of women it's just
what would I do if I was in an
environment surrounded by people who
were a third heavier than me and a third
stronger than me and they could
potentially punch me in the face well
I'm not gonna box them am I like oh I'll
be a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu act but no I
have to work psychologically I have to
work emotionally we have to work on
reputation you have to use the tools
that you've got 100 and I think that's
one thing that
um and I'm certainly uh I want to give
balance to a situation you know because
men and men and women are under very
different kinds of threats I feel like
and that's sort of a subtlety that seems
to be glossed over in society now
because women don't feel safe
um you know we've got women going
missing there's that girl who's just
gone missing we see and and with men
obviously by Nature they are more
violent so
um it is a lot easier at the spot when a
when a woman is in a traumatic
relationship because there will be there
were signs that are more uh obviously
leave physical marks men will Lush out
yeah but women if there's one thing that
I've witnessed uh in in friends
relationships is that level of
psychological uh bullying that men are
enduring out there right now that isn't
really spoken about because men don't
want to admit you know they feel like a
[__] they feel like a little [__] and
um they're being tortured to an extent
on a daily basis some of these guys and
it is very hard to to speak out but also
for other people to notice it
yes and like okay we've we've gone there
so so let's be let's be fully inclusive
there are men who also psychologically
torture women we call this like covert
or vulnerable narcissism
could go that way they just prefer that
um that's their prefer it makes them
feel more powerful than if they have to
be physically threatening you can have
in female female relationships you can
have covert and vulnerable abuse and you
can have Psychopathic abuse in male male
relationships and by covert you mean
like cleverly sort of yeah hidden where
you're abusive but you're not doing it
to a degree where people can put the
finger on you exactly you're seeing as
difficult rather than exactly and we're
into the Realms now where within
Psychiatry they'll argue about the
categories because why is it covert well
it's to distinguish you from what we
call the grandiose classic Narcissa
grandiose classic now says turns up like
Patrick Bateman red Ferrari super
handsome guy extremely promiscuous but
no empathy very very cruel so on and so
forth
now with the categories they're sort of
saying that's probably a psychopath so
it's all and then and then we've some
people in the community are saying when
we talk about narcissism it's all on a
spectrum of covert narcissism it's all
compensatory because if you feel very
strong you would behave psychopathically
and you can afford to behave
psychopathically if your position is a
little weak when you have to be more
manipulative you have to use narcissism
so yes like basically and answer your
question yes it is that and there are
men out there who are suffering the way
that women do just under psychological
abuse the difference is recipients as a
man who's been a narcissistically
abusive relationships is yeah it's much
harder I'm not equipped to be like oh
I'll go and tell my male friends or I'll
go to a counselor and say hey I feel
really unseen men don't talk like that
we don't have the [__] vocabulary I
had to learn it over years and be like
well what does it mean if you're unseen
well actually it's very painful because
yes I'm a man and there's an adult male
side of me that really isn't bothered
whether I'm seen or not but there's also
a child inside of me when we're in in so
you mentioned romance before
once we're in romantic relationships all
your armor is off and you become two
children together which is right which
is good it's also very dangerous because
your boundaries are down abuse can seep
into that that shared space but of
course your needs as a child then as
your inner child comes out go up you do
need to be seen you don't want to be
humiliated you don't want it really hurt
like if I humiliate you in public you'll
be like oh there's a bit of a prick
never mind I doubt you would it would
last more than three hours you'd be like
oh what a bell end and then you'd have a
drink and you forget about it if your
girlfriend who you trust does that you
go into a spiral it could last like five
or six days why did she do that does she
really love me can I really trust her
the the gamble is that much higher
you're risking so much more you've
placed so much more on that relationship
I'm I'm looking at you I'm kind of
talking to the man watching don't feel
ashamed if you feel a massive amount of
anxiety when you're in this situation
with a woman who's not done anything
awful to you you can go to the police
with but maybe she humiliated you or
maybe she devalued your needs and you'd
be like well why am I so weak think
about the gamble how much of you how
much have you invested how much have you
staked on this one relationship what's
the pain and the cost if it breaks down
tomorrow if it's high no wonder you're
anxious you have a right to be anxious
you have a right to be frightened and as
a man we are at a significant
disadvantage when it comes to legally
separating if you're in a marriage or
for example because you will get butt
[__] in prison uh sorry in call
I'll say that one more time
mate
[Laughter]
okay people understand what I'm saying
is that you will get Beaufort and caught
like men men don't have the same rights
as women if there's children involved
and all of that and that's why
in those relationships
uh men
they don't have the same power as when
they first met that woman you know what
I mean as things change and
um and when women become aware of that
and if you're with someone who is that
we inclined to use things in that nasty
way your
you are going to feel that cloud above
your head like oh God like you know how
do we navigate the scenario and that's
when men do spiral from what I can tell
100 well I mean I I coach uh and I work
with a 90 female audience and I've been
doing this for 10 years so I have the I
really have a much much better
understanding of the female perspective
now and what I would say is for the men
um if you think you're just going to
jump on the mats with a BJJ third degree
black belt an emotional manipulation
because you have a bit of banter with
your mates at the pub she's gonna snap
something off you're such a great way of
describing it by the way then you'll
never recover yeah that's what I went
through because I was like I have degree
in Psychology let's see what you got
I was like wow that hurt and it took me
years to get over it and this she wasn't
even really trying it was her natural
spontaneous just because from the age of
12 13 women and young girls in secondary
school we have a problem with the girl
in my family I love her but she's she's
15 and I take her boxing I take it
through weights she's tough man she's
hard going
but
like you said you use the tools that you
have so young men we play fight we
wrestle what's she doing she's clawing
everybody psychologically she's her
mother her mother the people in her
family because that's her practicing for
the real world so she's developing her
teeth and her claws now but it's
psychological so you think you're I mean
imagine we jump in the the ring with
somebody the same age as us who's been
doing Muay Thai since they're six just
every day every day every day banging
out the kicks they're banging out the
punches westerners we never catch up so
so on that I I feel like when I had some
of my relationships when I was younger I
was at a bit of a disadvantage because
I've been raised by a single mother who
loved me daughtered on me devoted to me
was just soft and gentle and kind and
then I went and met women
and I'm like see the way he said that
yeah women you know and I'm like oh like
and look I'm not saying I was a perfect
guy by any means you know but but
I had an expectation because of what I
was conditioned to yes whereas I was at
a major disadvantage in this game
because I didn't even know there was a
game about to be played everyone to be
fair was going to be a step down in my
head from that but but some were a cliff
drop right and and for that reason so
when I'm in there with a manipulator who
has been raised by people who don't give
a [__] yeah like no love you know so
we're coming at it from angles and I'm
like oh no like this is not how life is
and my dad described it as this and I'm
going to use this example of he we were
sitting in the bedroom in the living
room once and he was like you see that's
carpet relationships are like that
carpet and you start off with kind of
like 50 each yeah and you start trading
and as the relationship goes on one
person will be gaining more ground you
know what I mean I was not aware that
this was even a thing I'm like let me
just be a nice guy not that I was super
I was smothering them with love nice
well I was I was just coming in with
good intentions yeah and there was times
where I was again wrapped up with a
strangulation around my neck with
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu style not really
understanding oh [__] we're playing this
game are we and before I knew it like
because that's why my dad was saying
things to me where I was like I've
rekindled sort of my relationship with
him he's like don't make them apologize
you regret it they'll make you regret it
yeah you know like as he was with a
woman who was conditioning him to that
and I was like [__] me uh you know I was
learning I learned a lot in that in
those early years you know I mean
they're not necessarily good stuff what
what what sort of age were you when you
started learning this stuff um I
remember having a moment where I was in
a relationship in my early 20s and and I
remember thinking I was being lied to I
was being lied to about reasons why I
can't go to the gym or reasons why I
can't do what I enjoy and be out with
the lads and and I was being and I
realized I'm being
conditioned Yeah Yeah by someone who
wants me to do what they want to do and
not for me to just be happy yeah you
know and as time went by
I remember thinking if I don't start
fighting back
in this relationship I'm going to lose
who I am yeah and that's me like um
people look at me like big strong alpha
male confident guy I was in a situation
where through through time yeah and
consistency yeah I was ground down into
a shadow of the man I was confident
outgoing everyone knows me Chuck the lad
to like asking if I can go for a drink
and and that [__] happens to men out
there where we're like we catch
ourselves one day and it's like when the
[__] did this happen and that was where
I thought you know what like if I don't
start telling you to [__] off yeah and
I'll do what I want I ain't gonna come
back from this and I'll be you know like
and I remember being in a relief I'm
really confessing now I remember in a
relationship with one girl
and she was talking to me like a piece
of [__] yeah and I had this moment and I
met her parents
and I noticed that her her mother would
talk to her father like a piece of crap
and her father they had um a couple like
three kids and he was really nice guy
and I grew up with my dad Bailey being
there and you know Papa Was a Rolling
Stone and I'm like you know your dad's
actually like a great guy and you guys
don't taught him the way you should like
provider you guys have never wanted for
anything paid your University fees like
you've got everything that I didn't
necessarily get you know what I mean
um and and she started giving me that
same attitude that her mother gave her
dad and I remember like being like a
couple of weeks went by and I was like
whoa yeah I see where this is going I've
seen this unappreciated man in the
corner yeah just getting his little
guitar time in when he could just the
only time he's ever [__] happy was
when he was alone with his guitar and
I'm like bro that ain't gonna be me yeah
I want to be spoken there with respect
or not just balls on top of the
refrigerator oh it's playing and I felt
so sorry for this poor little man I'm
like you're a lovely guy and no one
respects you you know why because you
haven't fought yeah and there was a
point where and like many men do um he
thought it was easier when he was in his
20s or 30s to say Yes dear yeah but you
know what that yesterday was to give him
an easy life it ended his life yeah yeah
his any chance of any any worth and
happiness was gone there because he just
handed his ball sacked over at 100 100
sorry I'm off my soapbox no it's okay
it's okay
um there's a little bit you need to get
out there yes it's three thousand
sharing three three thousand I I uh I
was laughing because I was just flashed
as you were talking flashing back to my
teens you know like I was a chef Family
Life eventually my dad ended up in
prison for what he was doing with his
with his family but I I dissociated I
went into sci-fi books and [__] sword
and sorcery novels and Magic LSD
Buddhism Sufism I was a little mystical
kid proper Little Hippie and then I'd
get the same thing like in relationships
I'd do okay with with girls and people
like oh girls really like you and I'm
like yeah yeah it's great and I'd just
be thinking it's all good it's all good
and then it'd be in these scenarios in
these arguments and I'm like I don't
even know what we're arguing like yeah
what what are you trying to do I don't
and it would slip past me for a couple
of years because I just didn't get it I
just let them do you couldn't cheat on
me you couldn't lie to me because I
didn't care I wasn't I was hardly in
this world practically and then slowly
when I got my degree and I got invested
in money and running a business and I
started to become material then it was a
problem then then I was like anger on a
second I'm getting out off here but I
started way behind way way behind I
turned 45 in two weeks I think I'm just
about getting it I think I'm just about
getting it seriously like it's it's not
it's not easy to begin with there's a
lot that men need to learn there's a lot
of software upgrades we need to get that
we just don't get and the culture that
we've created as you as human beings
right now just doesn't support that it
doesn't support you mean the the
learning of men to become more
um able to uh understand the language
and the manipulation that they can be
subjected to 100 yeah because we're
we're just not on their level women are
are leaps and Bones because they talk so
much to each other like again
I've I've had like
so few conversations with my boys about
like when they when like the real [__]
that goes on behind closed doors yeah
like how can you yeah it's embarrassing
right because the stuff you've let women
say to you that you would never want
anybody to know the stuff that you've
you've let a girl know you've been in
emotional state where you've been crying
and begging and you're gonna like who
are you gonna tell yeah you'll take that
to the grave as a man oh so like shame
guilt all of that locks us up that's a
further thing that can start to happen
before anybody gets too comfortable with
this and starts thinking it's just like
a red pill manage Fair conversation
I actually think there's a there's a
good and all men need to understand this
women do act and historically always
have had women are more important than
men because they produce life the only
thing that men can do is take life they
say the oldest uh job in the world is
prostitution right well the oldest job
for men in the world is being a killer I
can pay you I can give you a bead and
you can go and kill my enemy for me so
you have soldiers and prostitutes at our
most basic are almost barbaric that's
what we are we kill women can give life
they choose they're The Gatekeepers of
future uh Generations
I had this Revelation once I was
watching an alpha male lion not in real
life on a YouTube video on a rock and
the lionesses around him decided on a
dime collectively he was done being an
alpha male and they [__] went for him
that lion screamed in pain as they tried
to bite his knots off that you know the
uh the tendons and the legs of a lion
they're sinking their teeth into that to
get him off the rock the other Lions the
male lions run over and I think oh
they're going to finish him off now no
to save him the other male lions who
want his possession come over and save
him because these lionesses are like
your time is [__] done that shocked
me I laughed when I saw it and it the
the Lion's screaming and it's clear
distress like he's it's a [__] lion
he was the Alpha Lion the females got
rid of him in six or seven minutes and
he was broken he knew he was done he
wasn't gonna fight back he wasn't gonna
and I thought why is that that like that
those lionesses
it's not oh you're a good guy or you've
tried really hard Mr lion it's you are
not the strongest option and we are
genetically programmed we have to only
let the strongest option through mate
you're not it sorry about that sorry it
hurts your feelings I know this is a fun
fantastic point that you're making
because actually the more I'm learning
right now about the dating game is that
because of that and because of social
media I feel partly that's my own
opinion is that the the statistics vary
but apparently like 80 of women are only
trying to [__] 20 of men yes I heard
that on uh Chris Williams Chris is a big
guy who I'm listening to a lot right now
shout out to him love the guy I could
talk to him a lot but
um but also there's a lot of people
perpetuating that statistic as well and
there's a lot of data actually backing
it up where and and part of this problem
I think is social media as well because
we're getting to see the pecking order
it's right there like you know in
[__] World War II yeah you know you
meet a nice guy uh yeah cool you don't
really have the gauge the the the the
scale to look at the way you do on
Instagram recommended now you know the
girl I thought had a big book five years
ago I now see bigger butts every day
like you know and it's changing my brain
he had to become accustomed to a certain
thing and I'm sure women are getting uh
changed as well by that Yeah Yeah by
Becky Yachts yeah yeah [__] bigger a
lot of things
and and and and and that is human nature
and the nature of our species is to try
and seek out the not necessarily always
the athletically strongest but the
strongest of of the species in terms of
what they can provide and yes
etc etc that's that's another thing that
that I think men need to catch up on
everybody needs to catch up on like
obviously there's there's two men
talking here but it's not uh women are
bad men a good thing it's a competition
thing absolutely so here's something
that I'll say on behalf of women I don't
know how women have let men get away
with this we have a thing called a gold
digger right so a woman who only wants a
man who has good resources she's called
a gold digger and we allow that what do
you call a man who only dates beautiful
women
it should be called a beauty or a youth
Digger or why why do we get away
Leonardo DiCaprio's getting a little bit
of [__] for it yes they'll probably find
a name for him he's really taking the
piss this guy's 49 going up 19 year olds
Jesus it just doesn't give yeah but I
think like we have to start having a
more honest and open conversation about
the savagery within us all the savagery
within me the savagery within you it's
in it's in women that we are tough I
mean what we have gone through to get
here so there's eight million of us with
artificial lights and calories
everywhere in multiple different flavors
we have been through [__] hell and
back
there is a savagery to us like yes I so
I my thing now is like don't hate women
for wanting High resource Men and don't
hate men for wanting what they want in
women
why is it like this because Lord I have
a quite a famous geneticist in the
family uh published an artist and I chat
about to her about this a lot largely
speaking your looks as a child come from
your mum but your intelligence and your
resourcefulness come from your dad so
women are going to be looking for
somebody who means that their children
will survive it's all genetics we're
looking for a healthy good-looking woman
so that the children survive so that our
DNA passes on it's not conscious I'm not
trying to be mean I'm not trying to like
bypass a really good soul but she's not
that good looking I always say to people
like it's not charity this is survival
this is my DNA of course I'm going to
get in the competition and I think this
is where men fall behind is we're not
trained to compete we're not trying to
think of it as being a competitive space
it's like if I'm a nice guy because you
watch a romantic comedy and you watch a
Disney movie and you talk to your mum
that's what most of us did that's how
most of us grow up now if I'm a nice guy
and I do good things at the end of it
I'll be rewarded with a good girl good
[__] luck with that and until you're
poem going back to Chris's statistical
work is that more men than ever are
reporting a long time well I think it's
like a year without having sex yes
Mormon than ever are going without sex
yes but what's happening is at the top
end yeah those men yes be [__] more
than anyone yes I know I know yeah it's
a very busy schedule
and that's the crazy thing bro is like
yeah so you it's more lopsided than it's
ever been because now the ability to
connect with more people through social
media is right there so these men can go
and DM as many girls as they want get as
many girls as they want their schedules
packed and then you've got the normal
guys out there who and and these women
to be fair to them are looking at that
high value man and thinking here is an
opportunity not realizing
you're that ain't the guy but but
because genetics are imploring them to
go for the high value man yes they're
not able to sort of to think logically
about what options he's got yes because
he kind of is the bell of the ball now
this this man in question that I'm
creating yeah yeah and and these women
who are drawn to him unfortunately
you're probably not going to be the one
he chooses so the guys who you're
looking at thinking yeah he's not really
that that's probably where you're
actually going to end up ironically
after being and if that cuts both ways I
choose like I'm 45 I choose a really hot
26 year old do you think it's going to
work out well for me yeah exactly let's
go with tons of options in the in the
peak of her use and the peak of her
attractiveness yes she may have a little
bit of an attitude problem sometimes and
I I've actually took just to this point
I've stayed friends in the last five
years thankfully with ex-girlfriends
which I'm really grateful for because I
get great data from them oh really the
inside track so an ex-girlfriend of mine
she showed me two guys that she's
involved with she's a good looking girl
she has choice
and she's I joke with her about this
she's mainly there's one guy is
beautiful this is a very good looking
guy by any standards he's athletic he
easily could be a model
he doesn't keep her awake at night he's
not the one that she's obsessed with
there's this other dude God bless him
look if you put these two men together
you as a man because we we judge on
looks predominantly you'd be like
obviously the Chad not this scrawny dude
who looks like a chicken uh because of
the is his personality his status in the
world his access to resources she even
told me it's his connection to other
people she's like I know it's not
logical but this is what I want this is
what or rather this is what obsesses me
and the older she gets the more that
will appeal for sure that's what she
said yeah what she said she said the 24
year old me would have chosen the super
hot Chad but now she's looking at 27 28
she's like no this is and and I might
but is this spontaneous or do you have
to convince yourself to be sexually
attracted to him she said nope I am more
sexually attracted to him my body is
telling me to breed with that man wow
and we laugh about it I've sent her
screenshots I'm like so side by side
you're still saying yeah what are you
saying now here's him with the shirts
off on his Instagram
what are you saying she's like I can't
help this and she's like laughing and I
think no no in London the thing I
learned from London basically because in
Newcastle people still settle down
earlier I would say yeah uh but in
London it's you know people tend not to
settle down until like 30 to 40 or
whatever is even the men I feel are are
also taking it on board that now because
they're being conditioned a little bit
as well so maybe not so much on a
genetic level but men are also
interested in more in status now in what
women can do well uh yeah without
getting myself in trouble I suspect
that's because the gender roles are just
morphing me we're so true yeah like men
are becoming women women are becoming
men I mean becoming London was the Nexus
point for me I first saw this the last
time I lived in London was the last time
I lived in London I can't I can't
tolerate anything but the dating scene
there back in 2013 you'd see that women
acting like fellas and fellas acting
like women that's for me from Liverpool
I was just like what are you all doing
down here why is everything upside down
so yeah and and I guess it's because
women
in London uh the you know the financial
situation is is now women are kind of
[__] and I feel for them in that sense
in London because they're doing they're
[__] because of their own success yeah
they've gotten to a point where they're
earning such a good wage and they're so
intelligent they've done so well but
women don't want to date down
financially they want to so they want a
day oh but but the men don't give a [__]
men who are earning will be above them
they're like I just want a hot chick
who's going to look after me and be nice
to me yeah I don't give a [__] about
what you're earning generally and women
do care yeah they do present like you
know I've got ex-girlfriends I'm still
friends with I have a lot of women I
like to I like to to talk to women to
get you know of course like
and they'll say to me okay I've seen you
do this YouTube video and I've seen you
do the rans I just sort of did now
what's what's the solution for me I'm
like I don't know I'm so sorry I I don't
know what to tell you because
we can't issue individual solutions for
a societal problem you know that 80 20
thing that the the Chris William cited I
don't think it's 80 20. I I like I did
nightclub security again last year
because I just wanted to go back on the
door and just reconnect with the mates
and stuff it's not 80 20. you're talking
like 95.5 seriously there's not 20 of
men who are really
the I think the perception is they do
well with women so I know a lot of guys
there's a perception there is but
actually taking girls home and actually
it's it's a fraction of that my that's
my that's my opinion that's my opinion
it's actually worse
that makes sense because the attention
that like I kind of felt like I relived
my early 20s when you in terms of
attention when I became successful at
what and what age did you become
successful well I'll tell you like 30
for example you noticed at 30 you were
like hey I'm hot again yeah yeah it was
like a oh did I get a facelift
I'd put way on like what's going on here
and I think okay like I get it I'm
becoming something here that I wasn't
before you're really trying not to say
high value man well I don't like that
yeah but like it's it's Andrew Ted
speaker yeah yeah like I got this red
pill thing and we're kind of uh sort of
heading towards that a little bit with
this chart yeah and you know for those
who don't really understand how would
you how would you describe it as someone
to someone who doesn't understand this
red pill theory that men are gravitating
towards now it's a response to feminism
so feminism was a response to domination
so you have this Echo effect then
feminism comes along and you have your
suffragettes women going for equal
rights your first wife feminist ISM
sounds pretty good to me then it becomes
second wave third wave then by the
fourth wave it's women are amazing and
Menace yet let's get rid of them it's
very aggressive for sure super
aggressive and I think it's definitely a
tap masculinity in a way where we've
we've heard words like toxic masculinity
yeah and that's kind of and I'm not
saying that there wasn't a reason for
people coming up with that initially
yeah but it it has just become it's gone
crazy well and there's there's a
terrible propens I mean I studied
feminism at University and I found it
useful as a as a weapon system so if I
wanted to attack mainstream scientific
psychology which I didn't know how to
because I was I was annoyed with it
frustrated whatever feminism gave me the
tools to do that which to me that proves
it's more of an ideology than a true
philosophy it's a response to similarly
and it's kind of it's kind of therefore
intrinsically impotent in my humble
opinion similarly the red pill is
intrinsic the impotence it's an ideology
and it's uh
you know it hates women and this kind of
hates me yeah I've seen some of those
guys where and look they do make some
good points of course and that is why a
person like an Andrew Tate Rises to
Powers because you know they will say
some smart stuff yeah in in amongst the
things that whip people up and make yeah
yeah [__] them yeah you know and and on
both sides and I feel that way about a
lot of things Politics as well you know
like any far opinion usually is just
extreme and and yes there will be some
dollops of Truth in there but it is it's
nonsense a lot of it it is it's it's
nonsensical
um and I think the proof of that is you
go okay where's the happiness here
where's the joy here like you know you
got the mgtow movement I I've always
spoken to the mgtow movement in this way
and they take it thankfully because
they're what it's not sorry I don't know
mango their own way oh really literally
they just abandoned the playing field
and I'm like what what's that like
you're just never gonna get without
station and porn that's it and and sex
dolls I'm like are you kidding me and
then women have their cats and their
loneliness and and I can like when I was
first exposed in 2013 I had some good
online arguments some robust red-blooded
arguments and everything but it was a
bit of a joke it's not a joke anymore
like these statistics that are coming
out yeah people are having younger and
younger people are having less and less
sex and and it's taking longer and
longer for people to actually get in
committed relationships and marriage and
have children because if at all but look
our culture doesn't support it and do
you think from the narcissistic side of
it just to bring it back a little bit
obviously not you know it's a kind of a
medical thing narcissist but but in
terms of what I've experienced in
relationships in my life is more and
more people are coming into
relationships now and thinking how does
this benefit me yes what can this do for
me yes and at the point where not enough
people are thinking what can I do give
to this person and how can I make this
person happy 100 and I and I kind of
feel like some of the women I've met in
my life have gone like there's a
mythical man out there who will put up
with everything because I am perfect and
he will find me and he will realize I am
perfect and I'm like I'm looking at this
this person thinking while you're so
broken you are never going to meet
someone who is going to come along and
accept all of this craziness that I'm
dealing with right now and that and it
was funny because there was that that
one person I was referring to
I remember thinking like you're never
gonna have a successful relationship and
you know as you do you realize
um oh they've met someone I'm like how
how have you met someone how how have
you actually got a relationship that's
working and then I realized it was like
this on again African guy that she sees
like once in a while he lives in a
different country and I'm like that's
why he thinks you're good he hasn't
actually like had to spend multiple days
a week with you you're just doing nice
holidays yeah a weekend in Paris
everything's wonderful bro I was like
that's why because the minute you
actually move in with this guy and you
he will realize you are and it goes back
to the things that we said earlier in
the podcast about like those little
subtleties of are you like there was
things I'd say it just so innocently
offer up a vulnerability and I'd be met
with her
you know like that look in that very
response and I instantly felt like oh
I'm I'm I'm weird or I'm bad or I'm I'm
off or I'm wrong or and reality was it
was just you can't be vulnerable around
someone like that you just can't because
they will break you down slowly in that
scenario anything you say Canon will be
used against you that's just Weaponry
even though ammunition there's
there's so much that you said there the
first thing sorry the first thing that I
wanted to um uh deal with was yes
showing up to a relationship as a
consumer showing up to a relationship
was it having been indoctrinated from
childhood and consumer capitalism why
wouldn't you treat the person like a
faulty app why wouldn't you treat them
like a delivery of something that wasn't
quite right for you I felt like that I
felt the app you've nailed it yeah I I'm
I need I'm I'm a project yeah you know
you're good but I'm giving you a sex out
right now we can work this up in eight
um and that's inhuman I mean that's not
the meeting of two human beings
so you have like a narcissism light it's
not full delusional break with reality
but it's a narcissism light and it's
inculcated and I'm not saying I'm not
receiving any negative feedback from the
environment nobody's coming to me and
saying Richard
these these These Girls these women
they're people they're not things
somebody said to me recently um in this
culture we've learned to love people oh
sorry we're supposed to love people and
use things but now we love things and
use people so we've commodified for
humans and we're trying to consume love
and it's like was this the five-star
luxury holiday relationship I was hoping
for no it's not really good enough maybe
there's a better one swipe and you're
gone and it's like okay that's now we're
engaging and this is beyond narcissism
this is psychopathy that's a person that
you're talking to a human there they
were a child once they have pain they
have hopes they have dreams they have
fears you can't treat people like this
Chris Rock in his special called
tambourine in 2018 the bit that he
finishes with goes into he's not long
come out of a divorce at that point as a
multi-millionaire 49 year old at that
time he's got to start again and date
but he's also famous it must be a [__]
and he's saying retroactively what he
wished he'd done in the relationship and
he said you must sacrifice you show up
ready to sacrifice and ready to give for
the relationship both of you both of you
or you've got nothing
that takes it should be a giving contest
of course not not who can take the most
and that I I feel like that's where
that's where we are my previous
relationships have gone wrong in times
you know what I mean where and and look
I've I've definitely done that as well
because you know you slip into the Habit
as well if someone else is doing that
you again you get lost in this contest
yeah
um and when I've been at my happiest is
when I've been giving the most and when
that person has also been giving the
most yes you must you must both give you
must both sacrifice and people who find
that like if you're if you see that on
YouTube and you're like I want to write
a comment about that that's you I'm
talking to yeah you've got the problem
you lack humility you are not perfect I
am not perfect none of us are perfect
you're gonna like I'd love doing this in
seminars and people say oh you want a
relationship and they go yes I want a
relationship so I look into the crowd
it's mainly women I'll be like so you
want to live with one man in one house
for decades and they kind of go uh sorry
what were you thinking a relationship
was that's what it is you're going to
live with another dumb [__] human
being in the same space for years on end
and you think it's going to be like a
Non-Stop party and non-stop pleasure
that's insane only this generation came
to believe that nobody before believed
that that was because we're dopamine
faints we're not in that
we're not understanding that the boring
that's the good stuff yes and one of my
favorite speeches when we talk about
like um the movies is um is Robin
Williams and Good Will Hunting when he
talks about like you know the ways wife
would fall when before she died she
farted yeah she woke up the dog and I I
love the way he's like it's the crust of
a person it's not just a middle bit it's
everything yeah and and it's that boring
repetitive getting up every day yeah and
and just being around each other as your
other person that is the best bit about
it and I just feel like we don't because
people are chasing the grandiose
[__] yeah they don't appreciate that
I just don't see how somebody who is
subsumed in this culture has any chance
of doing an intimate relationship
whatsoever if you're into this culture
and the coordinates of this culture
you're screwed bro that is exactly why I
fired like those kind of like as as I
learned you know I got some painful
lessons bro I [__] this is me coming
from a man's point of view but when a
person makes you want to kill yourself
the way I felt after that situation and
unfortunately it's it's not just been
the one person I've had that feeling
with in my life but when they bring you
that law when they bring you to your
knees where you're questioning what is
the point in life if I feel so miserable
yeah when when anyone in a relationship
makes you feel that way a man or woman
[__] me get the hell out yeah because or
get the hell away from them as far away
from them as you can because they are
the ones who they don't care you are
just a resource to be drained and if
you're once your Surplus the
requirements we will just discard you
destroy you you mean nothing to that
person well you might even be they might
even have more of a serial killer
mindset they might they might see you as
a scalp and that's the the nastiness and
and that's something I don't have in me
as much as I might look like big
tattooed up guy I I'm an open-hearted
person you know and I feel like it's
really [__] me over because of when
you look into the the bottomless black
hole that
um this we've created in
um console culture and things like that
where I've been a a victim of that at
times and not that I didn't do anything
wrong because I was a stupid idiot but
when you feel that like when you're
looking into it and you're like wow God
there's not a lot of empathy out there
no and and and don't get me wrong like
there's a lot of people talking about
empathy yeah
uh yeah uh be kind you know when
Caroline flock uh you know put the poor
lady I took our own life and there was a
lot of that out there but the reality is
cancel culture I got right back to work
next week Baseline people they're good
the online world is violent narcissistic
Psychopaths and and that's what I'm what
I'm getting to is I feel like that
online mindset of of the online
psychopath it's creeping in there in
real life you wouldn't submit to that
kind of brainwashing under any other
circumstances and I was like I'm running
this particular party put on the VR
headset and listen to me talk to you for
seven hours a day you tell me to f off
but if it's entertaining or sexy or
funny we as monkeys just
I love the way you said that we as
monkeys that is that you've nailed it
yeah and I I that is part of the I feel
like the issue is it it is in in
infecting yes yes this the the
narcissism is coming through the phone
well it's like backwash yeah backwash
it's it's it's coming back and we read
the comments and you think
the most vocal lunatics the the lunatics
of any Village go online and scream
about the issue and you think that's
what everybody thinks about the issue it
is and most of us don't even bother
don't leave a comment I scroll past if
it's weird like but the lunatics they
hold the space I mean let's take for
example
um in in pop culture right now Sam Smith
is someone who is everyone's talking
about yeah but it's the it's the full
outrage yeah about him that I'm more
looking at and those are the
personalities who command the space as
you have like do they really wake up in
the morning and get really that outraged
by some geezer like you know no offense
to Sam Smith who's out of shape yeah and
and dressing up like a devil or a
[__] balloon animal
um you know again the guy looks like a
bit ridiculous but you're not really
that angry you're getting so angry
because that will get the the clickbait
the thumbnail the title every and that
will get you the reward
that the people who do this I always
think like a large majority of them have
to be unemployed they have to be well
Piers Morgan is a guy who does that
though that's his employment is to do
that yeah like his employment is to be
oh I'm absolutely yeah he doesn't I mean
does he really give that much of a [__]
about Megan and Harry no like it's
become his thing no he doesn't that's
how he makes money there's just no way
because I don't particularly like him
but I have to acknowledge like he must
have a fairly full life he must have a
full he's he's as famous as he wants to
be in exactly the way that he wants to
be that's a fulfilled human so no he's
not he's not looking at Megan and Harry
like my God I couldn't sleep a wink
until these two divorces for a guy who
looks like that right like no offense
appears but again he's not he's not
missed our child athlete you know he's
not a good looking human necessarily but
he is a fat old guy who shags a woman
who's probably well out of his League he
goes home driving a lovely car you don't
really give that much of a [__] you walk
in
whatever he is outraged white guy in
Britain who is put there to be a voice
of the voiceless you know and for those
white men who now feel like they're
marginalized I'm gonna be that guy yes
[__] you white man yeah people
colonizers we could say it there's
nothing they can do I mean really yeah
it's okay it's here for me and it's
interesting that peers in Andrew type
they did the interview together I
thought that was a good interview I
couldn't see it actually because I
thought I I really dislike both of you
okay
sorry I probably shouldn't say that yeah
not again you can't constantly for the
same thing twice that's that's true
that's true and UK If You're
independently wealthy try and cancel me
I guess they they in their combat they
brought out other sides of each other
which was interesting but I think that
they both play a game that like people
say it's okay it's just for likes it's
for follows it's entertaining diamond we
shouldn't be doing this we shouldn't
troll each other we shouldn't outrage
each other this is infantile exactly me
and that's why like a mate of mine sent
me a video some guy had made about me
the other day and and God bless him he's
a younger YouTuber he's like uh are you
all right I was like mate there's about
100 of these out there at least I'm like
no I'm not come around give me a cuddle
I'm like I'm not even going to watch
this I'm like this guy spent half an
hour making a video but I don't give a
[__] because again if I if I responded
to every one of these clowns I'd never
get anything done I wouldn't be happy
I'd be listening to people rip me the
shreds and say everything they hate
about me it it isn't conducive but again
there is a reward system there and that
is that is the reason that these people
are doing that going back to the
relationship side of it because I do
find this fascinating and I think a lot
of people have been there but if you're
trying to work out you know
is is my partner and not as narcissist
or am I a narcissist there's actually a
test for narcissism
I think came out in 2018 I can't
remember the American University but the
test was basically to say to people uh
students on campus
these are the traits of an artist
do you agree that you have these traits
or not and they would either say yes or
no and when they compared it to like
multi-factorial difficult
clinical tests that take 40 minutes to
complete it was about as accurate so if
you say to somebody who's highly
narcissistic these are the traits of
narcissism do you agree that you have
this they'll largely just tell you yes I
do
you can confront people with MPD and as
long as they don't think it's going to
disadvantage them they'll tell you yes
the internal subjective experience of
MPD of narcissism sorry for people who
have narcissistic personality disorder
is that this is not a disadvantage
I'm better than you what happens when
two narcissists are together is that
just chaos or I I suspect that the most
stable and probably the most common
relationship format is not narcissist
and victim or narcissist and codependent
it is narcissist with narcissist and
probably different forms power couples
for example power couples they last
longer
um with a narcissist and a codependent
the codependent's going to get tired and
they'll either like you know physically
leave this world
um or they'll start drinking or
something will break down well with
another narcissist of a different stripe
perhaps they're very Psychopathic
histrionic borderline they could be
covert with a grandiose
but as long as they both have that
fundamental fundamental narcissistic
core they can still get narcissistic
Supply and they can just live together
for decades on end and have a a dramatic
and confrontational relationship but
largely it will balance itself out so
it's actually the more normal I I
suspect as most narcissistic
relationships are actually with a
narcissist and a narcissist we think as
codependents oh it must all be a
narcissist finding a victim I know
multiple narcissistically abusive
relationships where people are married
and they just take it in terms to drink
each other's milkshake basically they
just abuse each other by Tone
wow it's sick it's really sick really
sick the way that you would know if
you're in a narcissistically abusive
relationship is if you start questioning
if you're in a narcissistically abusive
relationship if you start looking at
YouTube videos and Googling why is my
girlfriend got no empathy why is my
boyfriend so cruel to me the uh a friend
of mine once sort of confided in me uh
about such a a situation that they were
in of where like
yeah nothing they said was being taken
on board and and for a man as well to be
in a physically abusive relationship was
a real shock to me so he was the victim
of physical abuse oh really yeah and it
was one of those situations where
it was one of the rare times in my life
where people have confided in me on that
level and made me go wow like and as a
friend you're like well what do I do I'm
worried about like worried about the
health and safety of this it was it was
that serious yeah yeah but well for me
it was because I was on the outside yeah
and I'm like
when I'm hearing certain things are
happening and I'm like okay you came
home to walk like this happened or that
you know I'm like where's this going
because
if you've got a friend who's who's in
that situation who's you know you're
like well if you haven't got the
strength to and then I'm also worried
what happens if one day this guy he
snaps yeah because when a man is in a
situation where he's being
physically uh beaten and and
yeah it's like you know like have you
ever seen Me Myself and Irene where yeah
one day it all just sold circuits and
it's really good it actually he drives a
[__] car into a [__] building
because he's had enough of the life [__]
because he's missed a nice guy yes
that's what I was worried about I'm like
what happens if one day you turn around
yeah build her and The Whole World's
Gonna think you're a [__] in this that
and the other when in reality you know
this has been going on and it's been you
know it it's a really tricky situation
to be in where
you know there's no empathy
yes I I think the key there well look
like anybody can have a bad day A bad
month some people even have bad years
you know if they're grieving food the
mother or father they're addicted to
drugs there's things that can happen in
relationships where your partner can go
a little dark for a while and I think we
have to account for that where there's a
consistent pattern of behavior across
time and across context we really have
to start letting go of the idea that
this person is good for you you have to
despair you have to give up yeah and a
lot of us don't like giving up and
because we make exceptions for them
because and and excuses you go oh
they're going through a bad time at the
moment they're they're you know dog just
died or their dad died or whatever you
know there's there's reasons for them
not being in their best but
there was there was one relationship I
was in where that person was constantly
complaining about one thing or another
and there was Always Something There was
always a thing you know what I mean and
um there is something called a smile
because there's something negativistic
personality disorder which constantly
yeah yeah and and I I could guarantee on
any given day if I ask the question are
you okay are you you know what happened
today
or you wouldn't believe yeah it would be
the and I'd literally hate that sound
yeah I'd get to a point where you know
so
I just want to suck all the joy yeah and
out of you and everyone else yeah bro
and you know if there's one bit of
advice I could say to any man out there
first and foremost think of get yourself
a positive person yeah yeah you know
because positivity you know can take you
to a happy life you know no matter no
matter what and and being in that
scenario was brutal
um just feeling like constant negativity
but yeah it just felt like no matter
what I did I couldn't turn that
situation I couldn't do anything and
like you say
stop making exceptions except that this
is who you're with and I found that
really difficult you know the reason one
that I'm sorry to bang this drum it's a
cultural issue again we now live in a
culture it's extremely consumerist and
it's very morally relativistic we've
embraced post-modernism wholesale and
nobody realizes it they're like that's
some weird thing from University it's in
everything it's in everything we did
it's the it's the water we drink every
day post-modernism moral relativity and
there's an awful lot of ideas that we
have around that sort of social
constructionist and what all this means
is that psychology and psychological
ideas fundamentally seeped out into
reality so there's things that I should
say to you in therapy that are correct
in therapy you're my client and you say
I did a bad thing and I'm like let's say
for for this space I'm holding space for
you as the Americans say there's nothing
bad here that's a judgment and we'll
leave the value judgment aside you did
something in response to pressure that
you're on there you know the drill have
you ever been in therapy no well
actually well I was a little bit but a
little bit but you know this talk so
I'm not here as your therapist to assist
you in morally condemning yourself we're
never going to move forward
therapeutically we're not going to have
the breakthroughs I need you to have so
that you get better and move on with
your life I'm emotionally mature so that
space must be morally relativistic you
say I did a bad thing and I say it was
bad to you in that context but maybe
over here in another context it wouldn't
be
that's good in therapy it's [__] in
banking it doesn't belong in hospitals
it damn sure doesn't belong in the
[__] military or education we need
moral absolutism how are you going to
have a people who don't know right from
wrong of course we're all susceptible to
narcissistic abuse there's no right or
wrong Saddam Hussein was a bad guy yeah
but you don't know how his mum raised
them no he's a bad dude why because
killing people is wrong so the moral
relativists will say yeah but maybe in
his culture it's okay give a [__] what
your culture is yeah you know certain
things should have a hard moral boundary
we don't kill if we can't agree on that
we don't hit I don't if you tell me no
no means no it doesn't matter what the
no is I ask you you want to do something
or give me something you say no no means
no that's respecting your boundaries as
a human being
this is where we need to be and we're
swimming in a soup of moral relativity
and people think it's righteous they the
council culture Brigade they think this
is virtuous no everybody's everything
whatever you believe that you do in your
culture is fine no no no there are
boundaries boundaries are good
boundaries protect us so we're also in
an anti-boundary culture so it's it's
very hard for for any of us to assess I
struggled with it for years dude I had a
brand of martial arts training that the
Air Marshals took on I spoke to the the
[__] Air Marshals in Las Vegas every
month meanwhile at home a 24 year old
dancer was running rings around me I'm
teaching self-protection to American
special forces and Air Marshals and
police and back home I can't protect
myself from being humiliated by this all
that I'm living with insane totally
insane but when you say running rings
can you elaborate on how did you feel
what happened she was she had histrionic
personality disorder probably which
meant that she was hypersexual also
borderline very very emotional it's hard
about the smile when you say that
brother well yeah you're talking about a
24 year old dancer who's hypersexual
amazing
but yeah but I can understand how as a
man and how addictive that situation
could have been of like obviously you're
getting a reward there from everything
that you're saying yeah but then the
other patterns of behavior probably
chaotic I would assume a totally chaotic
and didn't didn't create an environment
of safety you know which is if you want
to love someone then you have to be
vulnerable you need to be safe and and
that is actually
um in my experience the the the best
relationships yeah are the ones where
you feel at your safest yeah yeah that's
a real big word for me yeah it's huge
yeah her father left uh she was she was
Chinese she moved to the UK when she was
four the father left and went and
produced another family back in Malaysia
where she was from massive daddy issues
refused daddy issues really loved
attention for from men when I say she
was a dancer she was a dancer in
nightclubs and she was an ex she was on
the British team for sports sports
acrobatics okay bedroom activities were
great
everything else outside of the bedroom
she just wasn't qualified for can we can
we explore the daddy issues thing then
if it wasn't for women with daddy issues
I'd be a virgin
um
like
it's definitely been a gift and a curse
to my life you're in that Viking daddy
absolutely That's What It Is Well you
know when women with daddy issues tend I
assume anyway they tend to like men who
look like they can protect them so this
has obviously been a fact there in my
life where I've encountered
the majority of women I've encountered
have had daddy issues okay so I'll I'll
there's there's little notes I've got in
my head that I have to bring up so let
me preface this with something that I
knew we would cover today
um every no segment Freud everybody
thinks the Sigmund Freud was like a
misogynistic finger wagging Viennese
gentleman who loathed women and feared
female sexuality not true nothing
further from the truth he was actually
very sex positive Sigmund Freud and
paraphrasing said that after years and
years of analysis of men and women
psychoanalysis he said sexual perversion
is so ubiquitous and so normal that we
shouldn't call it sexual perversion at
all so perversion what we now term
perversion is built into human sexuality
there's another guy who's in his lineage
of psychoanalytic theory called slavoy
jejek who's a Slovenian philosopher who
I like who says it's never just two
people in a room having sex there's
always a third element the perversion
The Fetish the fantasy whatever it is
that's how human beings achieve orgasm
and have really good sex so if you have
of anybody just so people know so he's
at the context because daddy issues is a
is a paraphilia and some people are
disgusted by it because they think the
daddy role play as she's literally
seeing you as her biological father now
that's gross and it's it's not that it's
a power Dynamic that is played for
safety exactly why I said protector yeah
yeah rather than you're not rather than
Dad rather than actual father which
would not which would be the opposite of
protection that would be a boundary
infringement and it would be
exploitation absolutely it's not
protected yeah so the word daddy is sort
of thrown in for as a I guess a
a way of putting a name on you you know
what I mean for women to to to to give
you that sort of title it's a status
yeah
and so there's a submission and a
dominance there but there's also a taboo
all humans like breaking taboos and when
it comes to sexuality you'll notice that
most of the things that get uh the
engine running are taboo breaking you
read like there's a woman called Nancy
Friday or at least that's a pseudonym
she did multiple books on female sexual
fantasies and male sexual fantasies I
recommend anybody scroll through look at
what people in the privacy of their
homes in the privacy of their own minds
look at what makes them have an orgasm
show me the the sexual fantasy that
doesn't have a boundary break in it even
if it's a guy who has a sexual fantasy
about his secretary or where's the
boundary break we shouldn't be [__] a
secret you should be [__] a secretary
there's something and there's a reason I
mean let's be real why uh the views on
porn videos are in the hundreds of
millions yeah of course like porn videos
seem to get more views than any YouTube
video I mean I mean the the money in
porn just grows every year the the
statistics for only fans alone I mean
it's ridiculous and I support to
um an only fans girl as a friend just
nuclear at one point and and some of the
things I found out about her customers
and what they'll ask for it was never
normal you know it was always a bit odd
a bit different yeah it's a paraphilia
there was always something as you've
just said yeah there was always a
perversion it was always a kink that got
them off well and and the reason why I'm
prefacing it with this is we spoke about
the online Council culture and the moral
outrage Brigade Aid and the people who
clutch their pearls are like oh my God
you're like daddy role play or whatever
the thing is so do you you all like
something you're either asexual or you
have a perversion yeah get the [__] out
of here no no I'm purely vanilla you're
not the psychologists have spoken we
know from all the data we know from porn
searches we know from work by people
like Nancy Friday everybody has a third
element all of us we need it it's fine
it's totally fine this should be seen as
an as a third element it's a desire for
protection it's about safety Within
um the daddy roleplay model safety is
built in because uh don't take this
literally folks it's psychoanalytic
theory it's all symbolic a father cannot
not on daughter his daughter it's a bond
you can't there's nothing you can do
like a father
you can't terminate that relationship
it's an interminable relationship a
daughter can't abandon her father father
can't abandon the daughter safety is
built in so people think oh the fantasy
is all about hardcore porn and like
athletic yeah there's an element of that
but it's in a context of safety that's
why it's appealing
the mail gets something from it the
female gets something from it in gay
relationships it'll be the same thing
somebody's atop somebody's a bottom
there's dominance and submission there's
sadism and there's masochism this is
just yin and yang and human sex and as
you say it's not it's it's the orgasm is
really the end of of like there there is
a lot more going on whether it be uh
financial and all sorts of things going
on um I've been in two relationships
where the daddy thing was proven to not
just be sexual in the way that you're
talking about because the goals would
forget and we'd be in the supermarket
and they'd call me Daddy I like this
there's people here yeah one girl did it
in front of her mum and I was like oh
great thank you very much it's not even
getting any ideas
yeah I I totally get it and like for me
personally it was never the thing it was
it was it was always something that I
sort of uh accepted because I was like
all right I get this and I I you know
you're in a relationship you always want
to meet you each other halfway whatever
that is
um why do you think that women do have
these daddy issues and then choose to
try and create a new situation with it
with a man under that same title I think
um what I'm noticing and and I actually
haven't looked at the research for this
but probably back at is the daddy
fantasy is actually more prevalent now
than it was like 20 years ago
um
it and I think it's because there's a
lack of Father figures there's a lack of
men that is the ultimate man that is the
man that's the first man in your life
that is the ultimate male Authority and
is it because also maybe that men are
becoming so feminized 100 that women are
craving yeah that figure so so say if I
go online it's always a it's always
going to whine people if I if I'm
biologically essentially men like this
and women like that and it upsets people
and and women will get more vocally
upset typically the Memoir they hate it
they're like you I didn't know you're a
secret misogynist I didn't know that you
were this phobic and that phobic and all
these words get thrown around but my DMs
fill up
so you're outraged and you're aroused
this is this is human nature this is
this is what we are we are hypocritical
creatures we're contrary creatures
you're like I hate that oh I've never
been more harassed that's disgusting oh
let's go and have sex it's that's the
dynamism that we require and a woman who
find those arrogant men you know who
love themselves yeah you know they find
them annoying but also oh so annoying
yeah yeah there's also that attraction
there of I don't know why but women do
like men who are very overly confident
for example you know it's it's again
we're back to
let me preface this just really quickly
so I don't I don't lose people
the solution to all of this like what
I'm about to say we've spoken about the
savagery that's inside of men and women
is humility and a sense of humor like I
have to accept that the goal I love that
I live with she's biologically
programmed like this and this and this
she needs to accept the creature that I
am I accept the creature that she is if
I hate women or a core of me hates an
element of women we have no chance if
she hates men or an element of her hates
so that aspect of men I'm a man we've
got no chance I have to forgive her she
has to forgive me in humility we meet in
the middle with a sense of humor and we
find a way to compromise our way around
it
the Instinct
um here I think between men and women is
is it's intrinsically different
I I've said this to my female friends it
drives them crazy but they always thank
me for it afterwards
women like not all women
many women like men who seem to be
arrogant and narcissistic and
Psychopathic because it is seen as
intrinsically masculine the essence of
masculinity in the yin yang framework
is Yang they are the guys who survive
they are the providers they're the
providers they gather our tapes and
they're not nice they're not submissive
they're not you know what compromise
yeah because back in the days when it
was important to to kill and to [__]
hunt and all of that you you didn't want
to be nice for them these are dudes who
are good at smashing the enemy's head in
and then falling asleep and sleeping
like a baby soldiers and prostitutes
exactly we're back to barbarism soldiers
and prostitutes
so women will get frustrated with
themselves and be like I always go for
these bad boys I had a another female
friend of mine she's uh she won't mind
me saying this she's she's she's she's
from Serbia and she's like I fell in
love with a guy and I'm so ashamed it's
so embarrassing and I was like show me
his pictures I can't I'm such a tit and
she showed me this guy who looks like
the
um sort of the amusing stereotype of a
Balkan gangster he's got the chains he's
got a white BMW he's got wraparound
sunglasses I'm like are you kidding me
look what you are that's I promised so I
wouldn't laugh and then I left her for
about five minutes she's like I know I
can't help it I don't know what is in me
and we talked about it and I said no
because
you should see the things that excite me
about women it's embarrassing it's
childish like when a woman shows herself
off or she's very very sexually
confident or she flirts with other men
or she's or she's showing off her body
am I am I a [__] I teach psychology for
a living am I stupid and a part of me
goes yeah you're dumb you're a dumb
human you're a monkey you're a monkey
okay to be a vulgar but without using
swear words like what is making the
blood rush to the parts of my body that
need blood it's not an intellectual
stimulation yeah like at my brother has
become a thing is because short clips of
girls bouncing their asses around get
men yep keep them swiping that's that
dumb monkey brain and it's not you know
we might all want utopianism and to
prettier up and to idealize it but what
caused human beings to be here a lot of
thrusting and gasping and like moaning
and calling each other Daddy and role
playing and switching it up and that's
why we're here you might not like it but
it was an awful lot of heterosexual
activity and people coming in each other
that ledger so go going back to the the
daddy thing yeah have you ever found
that it could backfire though because
obviously your your
you're trying to be there in in a role
that
the
um
the jokiness and the playfulness of this
whole you know think that some girls
have
um they they do speak to you in a
different kind of way once they see you
as that person I found anyways yeah
there's a little bit more of a of a
respectful tour and they they treat you
a little bit more of a as a senior
figure in the relationship you know it's
funny just to help me stand up
thank you young lady
um but but sometimes that can trigger
um I don't know maybe the trauma if they
died of leaving them abandonment issues
and I've had moments where girls have
been like
weirdly emotional out of the blue and
I've been like you're not angry at me
are you you're angry at your dad and and
like that immediately like crying and
you know you give a hug and have you
found that that's happened to you a
little bit or yes maybe you're not quite
as obvious as that well I mean what
you're describing I wouldn't say is
particularly unhealthy there's a moment
of Shadow activation that's a sign of
vulnerability you were getting closer in
terms of intimacy
like I guess I should say it like
sometimes acts of abuse that they're
taken in a single moment snapshot that's
abuse
actually that can be because the
relationship is progressing she's spoken
to you in a way that was very rude or
very distractful or you said something
to her that's actually because you're
progressing and you're you're showing
each other that shadow side this avowed
side of yourself
I went into counseling for for what
you're talking about and my counselor
back in 2010
um when I told her about this this role
play thing and the the safety of the
role play she said yeah but also this
girl can do anything to you and she
feels like you won't abandon it that's a
problem she feels like she can abuse you
she can flirt with other men she can
disrespect your boundaries and because
you're her daddy unconditional love yeah
which isn't a relationship that's not
the rule that you're really in nope yeah
and so which is without getting
sidetracked again like that's an
interesting thing that we think adults
should have unconditional love for each
other and I'm like um I think
relationships probably need to be more
conditional not less
um you can love a person you can love
them even if you're not in a
relationship with them but be careful
with saying we should be in a situation
of unconditional lovers to adults also
it's not true your love is actually your
togetherness is actually very
conditional why do you want it to be
unconditional is my question it's my
worry it's a [__] good question if
someone says that I'm like well why
though yeah if you're never going to
hurt me yeah and you know you're never
going to hurt me you don't have to worry
about that yeah if you need it to be
unconditional it's because you're
planning on some wild [__] no I'm not
down for that that's good that's good
that shows me that you've really been
hurt anything because you're ready
you're like that hey I've got my shield
and my kill on man
I see where this is going yeah no I mean
it's it's it's not a realistic
expectation that's not a realistic
expectation but yes I ended up in
counseling and I remember the counselor
saying to me the reason part the reason
why your girlfriend is doing this to you
is because you've allowed a role play
that should have stayed in the bedroom
to burst out the bedroom into real life
and now she you are her father
so you can you can never leave the
horrible thing about that was I really
struggled to leave her even after this
she eventually cheated on me she
eventually consummated there she was
flirting with other men and then
eventually she got with another guy and
why couldn't I leave her was it because
I loved her so much no it's because I
was her father she was younger than me
and that's probably why she felt like
she could cheat on you because almost
she's not really cheating on her
boyfriend yeah you're you're above that
almost exactly exactly and then I was
that we did nine months of horror it was
horror obviously once the trust is
broken it's just the disgust it's brutal
it's horrible yeah but I what kept me in
it was it lost a little bit was it that
I loved her no because that was broken I
felt guilty every time I tried to get
rid of her I'd have these protracted
long psychotic fantasies where her life
would fall apart without me in a way a
father would having anxiety about his
child so yeah we've got to be careful
with this stuff really careful
wow yeah I think that's a great point
about keeping that sort of dynamic
confined to the bedroom yeah
um because you know and the bedroom will
be fantasy and the relation healthy
relationships are rooted in fantasy you
have a shared fantasy with your partner
of who you are it's totally fine
navigating the specific boundaries of
the fantasy is the real skill I think
yeah that's a great point because
it's supposed to be playful it you know
and it's it's supposed to to to not get
too serious to not become and and it
sounds like that just came out of the
bedroom and just took all the the whole
thing yes it did it it really did and it
was
I didn't realize how much of that was
being powered by her and how much it was
powered by sex I was 30 years old this
was the hottest goal I'd ever been with
by far she wanted sex all the time and
she was deep into this daddy thing and I
was like this is like the best thing
ever yeah in the beginning 12 months
later I was a shell of myself I've been
in a situation like this before where
sex and controlled me yeah you know I
met a girl who I thought I had the best
you know sexual experience with and I
couldn't get enough of that and what I
found and I think that I'm the reason
I'm bringing this up is because I think
a lot of men do this is
that reward system
at the start it's it is that hit of wow
this is unbelievable more more more and
the more little red flags were popping
up I was ignoring them consistently
because I was like I can't get enough
because you're an addict yeah I was I
was oh yeah I was like a crackhead mate
and it didn't matter how damaging the
situation was yeah and I remember there
was one point where
an eye-opening experience of her
screaming and shouting like a lunatic at
me and I was like what how did we get
here you know what I mean it's it's
because as men
you are willing sometimes to overlook so
many things when you are with that
hottest girl of your life type [__] yes
I think I'd so we're back to that
biological determined biological
sensitism thing men are very very
motivated by sexual fulfillment but just
to add a little Nuance to that I don't
know if you found this to be true I
think actually men are also within that
Paradigm intrinsically emotional the
best orgasms I ever had were with goals
I really loved and I was like hang on
but if I'm just this Psychopathic
Warrior sex machine what what does that
mean because it should be really great
as long as she's hot as long as she's
hot as long as she's hot and it actually
hasn't proven to be true for me and the
reason I bring that up is that what
keeps you stuck in that relationship
first level sex
but the second level why is the sex so
good because you're in love
and and that seems to turn on a
different system that allows the sexual
experience to be better maybe feel safer
in my ex I don't know if you found that
to be true but like the sex was just way
better also yeah you're not afraid to
share more to be more you to push those
boundaries and explore everything that
you want
um
we were so [__] greedy it was
disgusting we were pigs I love it and I
think that the the thing with women
though is I think that and the thing
that I've understood a little bit more
lately about women is that
they don't understand
I understand that they're nowhere
motivated by sex but I don't think they
realize what a need it is for a man
almost you know and I get that it varies
from a man but but because women don't
have that same need their needs are
different they can kind of I kind of
feel like they dismiss it a little bit
in their head of how important sex is to
a man and and going back to some of my
experiences when a woman said no in a
relationship to sex for me that was a
moment of like oh I really am hurt like
hurt emotionally not just yeah not just
no physically uh you know I'm not
getting what I want but it was a war I
feel so [__] rejected right now like
if you don't want me sexually and I get
that it's not the language women speak
in the way that men men she may have
been in love with you she may have been
like no I want you emotionally yeah yeah
and and I'm not even you know I'm not
even criticizing that you know it was
one of those we'd had an argument she
wasn't in the mood I'm like let's make
up oh okay you know classic man no but
it oh it wounded his because I was just
like I already feel like [__] about the
argument we had I'm trying to make up
over here and now I feel rejected on a
sexual level yeah and I just don't think
that
I don't think that women quite
understand that as you've just rightly
said when you when you combine sex with
that emotional connection how important
it is for a man and how how much we need
that uh positive reinforcement on a
regular occurrence
one of the few things that I see has
been good about the development of the
technology that's inevitably going to
lead to us being in the metaverse and
virtual reality and pods that's our
future as human beings sadly and that's
unless there's a revolution or a major
war
um is is the ability potentially to
create empathy so I will know one day
possibly in my lifetime if technology is
there really what it feels like to be a
woman and a woman will really know what
it feels like to be me and I imagine if
we did that a few times and you come out
the pod
I think it would change the way we treat
each other and obviously we don't have
that now but what we do have is
communication yeah and I think that
that's one of the problems right now in
relationships that if people I know is
because people are starting the
relationship off and this is me included
in the past for sure of of
um
protecting yourself you're kind of
coming in with a uh you're not giving
everything and and you're kind of
waiting to see whether or not this
person is the one to give everything to
yeah but you kind of [__] because
if you if you don't go for it at some
point you end up 10 years down the road
in a relationship where you've never
really given everything you've never
really opened up because you're waiting
for that moment where and yeah you've
committed along the way but you've never
fully let it all out and um yeah I think
for me that's been one of the things
that's benefited my life in
um you know the last few years has just
realizing to just be real and just to be
you yeah you should like at least
to be you to be vulnerable at least if
you're being rejected it's you that's
being rejected and you can courageously
endure that and have humility and a
sense of humor and go well that [__]
sucks bro it's brutal it's brutal when
you're really you and you feel like they
they don't it's not necessarily like I
felt rejected when when I when I had
that moment of kind of Rejection it was
more like you don't love me enough
you know that's a that's a more of a
complicated feeling where you're like
yeah you love me but your ceiling of
Love ain't my ceiling of love I'm the
I'm a I'm a I'm a bit of a [__] even
I I wouldn't say I'm a classic romantic
but I'm a like I'm a hard lover like
that sounds so [__] Oh Daddy
you know what I mean there's a clip
there you go
I'll tell you what
I love hard okay as in like I give it on
my old you know yeah yeah and and so
when when it doesn't come back in that
level you're like I've got to let you go
and I as much as I like you and I love
you and all of that you're never going
to be that person who's going to give me
back what I'm giving out it's it's
interesting you say that because I think
I like the old self-defense business was
called street fight secrets and it was
for Lads at the front edge who needed to
fight with their bare hands and your
head putting each other and eyebrowsing
each other all that
they would often be the most romantic
men their fantasy uh not sexually but
emotionally about women frightened me
when I would talk to them and I'd
interact with them and they'd tell me
about the problems they had with their
wives and the problem the Special Forces
guys who'll [__] shoot 10 Lads in the
head and then go and have breakfast
terrified of approaching a goal in a bar
or terrified of having a an argument
with their wife
so when I see guys who are more at The
mascular Who present more masculine who
do their power lift and their
bodybuilding and all that
I always wonder like is this like one of
my clients from back in the day when
there is this and I think it I'm not big
on genetics describing personality thing
but I have this suspicion that there's
like a warrior Gene and a soldier Gene
and it's kind of
um
dangerous on one level to the enemy but
dangerous to itself within Camp because
I'm loyal
I'll do my duty I won't leave even when
I should leave even when I should
because I don't give up I'm not I want
to stick with this and there's this
ethos that makes you very very
attractive to dangerous women and also
very very unlikely to leave when you
should I'm not I'm not leaving I don't
quit I'm tough I can take this she has a
few problems but I'm a tough guy and I'm
five years later you know the light's
slowly dimming from your eyes and you're
exhausted and yeah if there's if there's
two qualities of mine that I feel like
I've let be abused in the past it's it's
loyalty in generosity right it's a very
masculine trait yeah and I feel like
there are two of my best and worst
qualities because again it's like
uh women and friends that you know you
you can be too loyal to a point where
you're a mug and I've definitely felt
that way you know and uh it's just
important to
to not to not be too nice and I think
you know there'd be a lot of young Lads
listening to this and uh it because we
we view those qualities as such great
things but then but they're not always
you know what I mean like nothing should
be boundary-less yeah this world nothing
nothing there's nothing you should give
in a boundaryless way it loses all value
if your loyalty spunks out everywhere
the first opportunity what is it it
doesn't mean anything yeah same with you
know your generosity
like even if you have the money to buy
people dinner all the time it took me
years I was 40 before I learned this
don't yes you've got the money yes
you're richer than they are but you
can't live like this it's not right and
it corrupts them you're you're I'm
corrupting my relationship with people I
really care about [__] so true
because you turn the dynamic of
friendship into provider receiver and no
good deed goes unpunished you're
creating resentment and you'll feel it
oh mate I didn't even realize until it
was too late yeah I swear to God in in
many many instances I I
I thought give more people will like me
more so wrong like it's it's crazy but
people they they do resent you know they
they begin to look at you like in with
entitlement oh yeah I've got them they
don't appreciate anything I've got the
knife marks in my back to prove it mates
it's so weird it's got to the point now
where I have friendships at the moment
with uh ladsu younger than me who are
struggling financially and I know how I
used to handle this years ago and I know
what I would have done and I'm like
because I want to keep this guy as a
friend in my life
who do I set a boundary with not with
him he's not coming to me and going
you've got money give it to me I'm
setting a boundary with me I'm like this
I'm trying to put the hands reaching for
the wallet might don't [__] do that's
weakness that's cowardice he has to
learn like you learned he has to grow
like you what do you want him to be an
infant let him [__] learn let him
grow let him suffer and and it kind of
makes me feel sorry for some of the most
successful people out there that I know
of like
you guys don't even know who your
[__] real friends are no and you
never will unfortunately because you've
gone beyond the point of ever
like with me I've had great moments of
of
um huge uh folds from Grace where I've
had to like really look around and go
who are my true friends and
unfortunately a lot of the time they're
not who you thought they were right but
it's a blessing as well because you find
out the people who you didn't
necessarily look at as the closest they
show up out of nowhere and they're like
I'm your guy actually yeah and it can be
a really
um a gift and a curse again but the guys
who I know who who have gone to that
Mega success part of YouTube they'll
never have those big Falls where they
lose their money or they become a dirty
word and they have to look around and
see who their true friend it'll never
happen because they're just beyond
they're bulletproof right and you'll
live a whole life never really finding
that hour
that sounds like hell on Earth I would
hate that I'd hate to be living slap I
was left right and Center me so you live
in a simulation there was I used to do a
Russian martial art called Systema and
uh they wouldn't use mats when you
trained they would let you fall on the
concrete and they would say a mat what
did they say the mat is your bad friend
because it protects you when you're full
the floor is a good friend because it
hurts and shows you where you need to
break fall better and I was like [__]
that's what I need I need hard feedback
from the environment from my friends to
feel alive and switched on being told
I'm amazing uh it gives me this weird
like I'm sinking into a matrix
simulation thing and out of out of those
friendship groups in my life it's the
ones it's the lads who were like the
real ones who give you that hard advice
they're the ones who are thereafter yeah
yeah the ones who aren't sucking up to
you the ones who are just just treat you
like anyone they'll be weird they'll be
eccentric they'll be correct sometimes
they will they're difficult dudes or or
girls but yes they're thereafter they
didn't give a [__] before so they don't
give a [__] afterwards absolutely so
they have to be outside of the
simulation yeah the bubble so true this
has been a fantastic Chutney I really
loved it really enjoyed it honestly
enjoy it you're a good dude and I hope
people got something from it I've tried
to be his car if they didn't we did we
definitely did not uh shout out all the
daddies out there love you I'm the daddy
lovers respect thanks for keeping us in
action
um do check out Richard's uh content it
is fantastic you've got a YouTube
channel Instagram all of that I'll put
the links in the description below I
would love to do a part two lovely yeah
let's do it and uh yeah enjoyed it don't
forget to subscribe like the video if
you haven't already and we'll see us on
the next one cheers